retrouvez des liens avec leurs adhérents
c'est l'un des trois sujets d'inquiétude
des associations qui ressort d'une
enquête le 8 juin dernier du ministère
des sports cette année on sent qu elle
pose plus la question parce que l'année
dernière a été extrêmement chaotique
crois que c'est 80% des cours qui ont
été annulés donc c'était une charge
enfin ils ont payé pour rien c'est pour
ça qu'on a décidé de faire un geste
quant au niveau financier et de réduire
de plus de la moitié des cotisations
pour les anciens certaines associations
ont pu profiter de la vitrine des jeux
olympiques à elancourt mort par handball
les médailles d'or des deux équipes de
france font la régie sur les catégories
jeunes effectivement un bandit c'est
moins de 12 on a beaucoup on a été
beaucoup sollicités on arrive
aujourd'hui pratiquement hausse au
maximum d'adhérents qu'on peut actuelle
sur ces catégories là les fécos vide on
le ressent un peu plus sur les
catégories à partir de 16 et 18 et
seniors pour effectivement
le passage du ter peut amener de la
perte de licenciés puis d'une centaine
d'associations s'est rassemblée sur les
deux jours du forum mort patients 3000
visiteurs étaient attendus sur ces deux
jours par rapport à ce qu'on avait perdu
voilà un an on a vu un retour
significatif sur les deux jours mais je
pense qu'on pourra faire de bilan
complet qu'à la fin du mois de septembre
contre les associations ont démarré leur
activité sur le début de l'année 2000 21
50% des associations franciliennes
estiment que leur situation générale est
difficile